dieser fall ist zumindest in meiner
journalistischen laufbahn vollkommen
einzuladen
konnte selbst einen blick oben in die
wohnung werfen in der mord geschah über
alles blut ist offen
der bauausschuss an der tochter
hinrichtungs artige inszenierung sollte
im grunde auf eine nachricht hin das
organisierte verbrechen
das ist im grunde der plot eines
hollywood films
vielleicht wäre er dafür sogar ein
bisschen zu unglaubwürdig
tatsächlich um das gefängnis
reingekommen es war nicht so ganz
einfach wir waren da in einem loch unten
da kam kein licht reingekommen luft die
sieben tage waren die hölle
wenn man die version der
staatsanwaltschaft nimmt dann haben wir
hier den vielleicht abgebrühtesten
killer aller zeiten
man kann die geschichte aber auch ganz
anders lesen
[Musik]
mein name ist kai feldhaus ich bin seit
2003 reporter bei bild
aktuell als chefreporter in der
nachrichtenredaktion und kümmere mich
dort um eigentlich alles was so in der
weiten welt passiert alles was an
schlimmen skurrilen lustigen traurigen
dingen in der welt passiert landet auf
meinem schreibtisch und so auch ein
überaus mysteriösen doppelmord in
paraguay
blut auf dem boden aufgerissene schränke
eine durchwühlte wohnung pure
verwahrlosung es ist der ort an dem
bernard von bredow und seine 14-jährige
tochter lorena nicht nur umgebracht
sondern auch bestialisch gefoltert
bisher ist der fall ein absolutes
mysterium es fehlt eine spur und auch
das muss
bernard von bredow war ein
bekannter deutscher paläontologe er hat
zum ersten mal für schlagzeilen gesorgt
da war er gerade 16 jahre alt hat er mit
einem suppenlöffel im bayerischen wald
gebuddelt und ist zur armut gestoßen das
hat er dann zu seinem beruf gemacht ist
als paläontologe um die welt gereist hat
in sibirien und in neuseeland erforscht
und hat in seiner bayerischen heimat ein
mammut museum gegründet er war
vielseitig begabt und talentiert
handwerklich offensichtlich sehr
begabten flugzeugen geschraubt und ist
dann vor etwa fünf jahren gemeinsam mit
seiner damals neunjährigen tochter nach
paraguay ausgewandert
hat dort ein haus gebaut und hat sich
vor allen dingen seinem hobby gewidmet
das war das restaurieren und verkaufen
von antiken streichinstrumenten
wir haben am sonntag in 31 oktober eine
e-mail bekommen das läuft bei bild so
man kann an die leser -redaktion
schreiben oder man kann sie anrufen und
sms schicken und wir haben eine e-mail
bekommen der betreff war deutsche
geologe und seine tochter am 22.10
mordet und ich kann mir ein kleines
stück daraus vorlesen ich bin ein
langjähriger freund und begleiter werden
von realos und sowie seiner tochter ich
würde mich freuen wenn sie den beitrag
veröffentlichen könnten um den druck auf
die ermittelnden behörden zu erhöhen ich
bin jetzt ihren wagen und
ansprechpartner und ansprechperson für
familie und behörden und daher mit dem
fall vertraute bestens aus paraguay
vielen dank für unterstützung
volker g mein kollege philipp
lichterbeck den ich seit jahren kenne
und schätze lebt in rio de janeiro und
deckt dort als freier journalist im
grunde ganz südamerika philips aufgabe
ist in diesem fall natürlich motoren der
redaktion zu sein wir wissen da sind
zwei tote deutsche die sind waren
überaus brutalen überfall ermordet
worden
wir wüssten gern warum mussten diese
beiden menschen sterben was wollten die
rolle
und wer war das
auf den nächsten flug genommen ging doch
in welchem land
10 uhr hierhin mit den funktionen
deutschen
[Musik]
war der beste freund von
weder den opfern
[Musik]
wir sind hier an dem ort in bern ab und
seiner tochter lorena beerdigt sind
schon ein bisschen trostlos aus aber wir
sicherlich in jüngster zeit morgen dies
ein bisschen netter gestaltet wir das
heißt die freunde bekannte und auch die
paraguayische bevölkerung hier sind
erschüttert traurig und wütend dass so
etwas passieren konnte
wie die tat genau ablief ist bis heute
unklar
was wir wissen ist dass am abend bis 22
oktober
mehrere personen
bernhard von brio und seine tochter in
ihrem haus bei aston überfallen haben
es muss dort zu einer längeren
auseinandersetzung gekommen sein darauf
deuteten blutspuren am tatort hin die
über
den gesamten tatort verteilt waren
spuren an der leiche von brenos deuten
darauf hin dass er vor seinem tod
gefoltert worden ist es gab dort
verschiedene verbrennungen zugefügt
worden sein müssen
gestorben sind beide schließlich an
schusswunden die tochter
er hält einen bauchschuss dann fand man
in der badewanne muss ich offensichtlich
verbündete
werner vom renault wurde in den nacken
geschossen also regelrecht hingerichtet
es gab dann mehrere live schalten
was könnte denn das motiv seien darüber
wird wahrscheinlich auch in diesem dorf
spekuliert ist kann ja eigentlich kein
normaler überfall gewesen sein weil die
beiden wohnen ja wirklich bestialisch
gefoltert wie konnte selbst einen blick
oben in die wohnung werfen und der mord
geschah und da herrscht ein ziemliches
chaos tausend sachen liegen
durcheinander es welche kleidung und im
blut lachen über alles blut ist sind
überall bluttropfen die brutalität der
täter dies sollte der bauausschuss an
der tochter die hinrichtungsart igge
inszenierung deutet im grunde auf eine
nachricht hin des organisierten
verbrechens im grunde sieht es aus wie
ein ein mafia boss nur darin schritt
überhaupt keine piste und es gibt auch
überhaupt keine bekannten verbindung von
bredow in das organisierte
kriminelle verbrechens mit
bernard hat
gebaut von ihren weltmeister er hatte
immer die idee viel zu überbauen viel
wohnraum zu schaffen das grundstück
hatte vor vier jahren erworben und sei
neben baut er hatte vor noch 400
quadratmeter mehr zu überbringen und im
raum zu schaffen raum für seine
forschungstätigkeit für ein labor für
sein werkzeug gut auch für
freischaffende künstler musiker
anfänglich ging man davon aus dass
bauarbeiter die tat begangen haben
sollen er hat von bredow hatte auf
seinem sehr sehr großen grundstück
verschiedene bauprojekte über die zeit
und hatte dann wohl ein bautrupp
engagiert den er gefeuert hat und dann
hat dieser fall hat diese unglaubliche
wendung nahm
das plötzlich drei ganz andere
festgenommen wurden
nämlich drei deutsche
und unter dem volk ag genau der mann der
uns auf diesem fall aufmerksam gemacht
hat der den kollegen für den richter weg
an den tatort gebracht hat und ihm noch
mit auf den weg gegeben hat dann war
mein bester freund ich will dass dieser
fall geht der sollte sich der täter sein
[Musik]
wir haben fotos
von dem west freute jetzt verdächtig ist
genau das brauchen wir
[Musik]
genau lasst uns mal in diesem versuch
mal mit ist der beste freund der täter
mit fragezeichen
die staatsanwaltschaft wirft den drei
einen komplott vor aber hier ist zeigen
wir anhand von brede das opfer soll zwei
geigen 2018 einen freund gegeben haben
damit er auf sie aufpasst der selbst
reist in dieser zeit hat das haus feuer
gefangen und die klagen sind offenbar
verbrannt
staatsanwaltschaft sagt jetzt dass das
nicht stimmt sondern dass die drei diese
geigen gesteckt hätten und jetzt sie
verkaufen wollten und dazu brauchen sie
eben aber das echtheitszertifikat und an
diese um an diese zertifikate zu
gelangen hätten sie rede und seine
tochter im gefoltert und umgebracht
wie kann der mann der gerade noch der
wichtigste hinweis geber waren der
troublemaker der da die behörden
antreibt jetzt auch mal tätig zu werden
wie kann der letzten verdächtigen werden
philips aufgabe ist in diesem fall
natürlich die staatsanwältin zu besuchen
und zu fragen was könnte da genau
passiert sein
[Musik]
wir haben mehrere hausdurchsuchungen
gemacht wir haben geigen und waffen
gefunden werden
wir haben auch eine waffe gefunden die
das gleiche kaliber hat wie die
tatwaffen
einer der tatverdächtigen wollte genau
diese waffe versteckt wir müssen uns
auch fragen warum man bei den
untersuchungen nicht mit uns
zusammenarbeiten wollte und warum er die
violinen und die waffen verstecken
wollte
wir haben auch stadt verläuft der
betroffenen und es gibt das problem der
zertifikate für einige der violine die
wir bei einem der beschuldigten gefunden
haben
wenn man die version der
staatsanwaltschaft nimmt dann haben wir
gehen vielleicht abgebrühtesten killer
aller zeiten der
seinen freund und dessen tochter die er
seit kindesbeinen kind umbringt oder
umbringen lässt dann die medien
alarmiert dann die medien zum tatort
ring und zum grab sind zur polizei
und dann aber als der täter überführt
wird man kann die geschichte doch ganz
anders lesen man kann auch diesen besten
freund als das bauernopfer der
geschichte sehen der nämlich das
internationale schlaglicht auf diesen
fall lenkt die medien ins land holt zur
polizei staatsanwaltschaft und sagt
ihnen ist berichten und die
staatsanwaltschaft sagt dann tun dann
gehen uns die noch nach vorn gucken aus
dem dreck am stecken kann und dass
irland der geschichte ist beide
versionen sind zum aktuellen stand
absolut denken machen
der dritte auftrag an philipp war
versucht doch bitte mal drei menschen
denen jetzt diese dieser doppelmord
vorgeworfen wird im gefängnis zu
besuchen und da zu interviewen